hey everyone welcome back to riotech
today we're delving into the future of
food and the exciting Innovations
transforming agriculture as we know it
if you're ready to explore the Cutting
Edge Technologies shaping the way we
grow and produce our food you're in the
right place first up we'll be discussing
the wonders of smart farming imagine
Farms equipped with sensors drones and
data analytics tools to optimize crop
yields and resource usage it's all about
enhancing efficiency and sustainability
in the agricultural landscape next we'll
explore sustainable agriculture
practices from eco-friendly fertilizers
to water conservation techniques Farmers
worldwide are adopting methods that
reduce environmental impact while
ensuring a Bountiful Harvest ever heard
of vertical farming we'll be taking a
closer look at how this Innovative
approach to cultivation is changing the
game by stacking crops in vertical
layers making the most of limited space
and resources Precision agriculture is
another game Cher by utilizing GPS iot
devices and advanced Mach Machinery
farmers can precisely manage their
fields applying the right amount of
resources where and when they're needed
most and of course we can't forget the
role of artificial intelligence in food
production AI is revolutionizing the way
we monitor crops analyze data and make
informed decisions ultimately leading to
more sustainable and efficient farming
practices so buckle up for an insightful
journey into the future of food and
agriculture if you find this information
valuable give us a thumbs up subscribe
for more content and let us know your
thoughts in the comments below